the Joe Rogan experience I was reading
or watching a video rather today I put
on my Twitter about this this family in
Siberia that they found that it escaped
communist persecution they were really
religious and they moved to the middle
of Siberia and they found them one day
there and they had no idea of world war
two it happened they didn't did they're
missing out on like giant they had no
contact with the outside world the
daughters had never seen people before
dude were they like home-schooled the
kids
oh yeah I mean they taught them what
they could but they're all just barely
surviving that one of them starved to
death the mother starved to death
and it's a cartoon of it all so it's
real weird like you watch this cartoon
you know and this lady's just starves to
death in the cartoon yeah and the it was
growing their own food and hunting with
the Kimba they didn't have a bow and
arrow they've never gone so they would
set traps in the in the ground floor
like an animal's would fall in sticks
would stab them is that what they looked
like yeah
not long after they got found [ __ ]
sever a cement so they were I think they
were out there for that was 78 when they
got found I think so I think they were
out there pre-world War two so wrap your
head around that so they might have been
out there for you know 30-plus years and
that was the shock they lived in that
was the place they lived in and they're
there in the [ __ ] taiga man they're
in Siberia
there are a hundred and fifty miles from
the late the the nearest city they
walked they got 150 miles in and set up
shop because some of the people that
they were with and their religious group
were killed by communists some were
arrested and persecuted and they just
had to flee so they took off and they
they made a little comm unit there good
[ __ ]
good God freezing cold Siberia freezing
cold and starving to death
the mother starved to death to let the
kids live it's crazy they barely made it
and then they started growing some food
and they figured out a way to the
remaining people that didn't starve to
death figure it out
way to survive but they were barely
hanging on they were all barefoot when
they found don't they eat their mom
probably not right can't bring yourself
to eat your own mother right you might
eat your mom if you're starving she's
not gonna need that meat right you don't
wanna look what do you do do you starve
to death with her or do you eat her I
think she would want I think my mom
would want me to eat I know your mom
[Laughter]
[Applause]